heute hat die bundesliga heute haben die
36 vereine darüber beraten wie es
weitergehen soll in der korona krise die
ja auch den fußball unglaublich
beeinflusst derzeit und darum freue ich
mich dass wir jetzt zu geschaltet haben
aus frankfurt christian seifert den dfl
geschäftsführer der heute mit den 36
vereinen per video konferenz zusammen
getagt hat hallo herr seifert
wir werden bereit sein das waren ihre
worte heute auf der pressekonferenz
bezogen darauf dass wenn die politik ihr
go gibt die bundesliga wieder spielen zu
lassen dann auch die vereine bereit
wären gleichzeitig meldet sich aber der
vorsitzende der innenministerkonferenz
herr georg maier aus thüringen zu wort
und sagt er sieht eine fortsetzung am 9
mai eher skeptisch denn beim fußball
kommen sich die spieler nach sie atmen
gerade in zweikämpfen und laufduellen
tief ein und aus was sagen sie
zunächst mal ist es völlig unstrittig
dass der profifußball wenn er wieder
gespielt wird unter anderen
voraussetzungen stattfindet als andere
arbeitsplätze statt findet man kommt
sich im profifußball nah und wir werden
ein meter fünfzig abstand nicht
einhalten können alles andere wäre auch
völlig absurd zu behaupten genau deshalb
haben wir ein sehr umfassendes sehr
detailliertes konzept vorgelegt welches
hoffentlich den speziellen
voraussetzungen die nunmal dieser sport
mit sich bringt rechnung trägt in dem
wir eben ein medizinisches konzept
versuchen umzusetzen angefangen vom
training bis hin zum spieltag ein
organisationskonzept umsätzen bis hin
zum spieltag das genau diesen bedenken
rechnung trägt und damit ein problem man
machen wir das was jede industrie tun
muss die versucht an ihren arbeitsplatz
zurückzukehren
das wird die arbeit dass wir die
automobilindustrie sein das wird aber
auch in restaurants der fall sein dass
ich menschen näher kommen
und genau diesen aspekt muss man
rechnung tragen deshalb haben wir auch
mit medizinischen experten
zusammengearbeitet
die deren deren expertise dort
eingeschlossen ist der sicherste weg den
virus nicht zu übertragen ist aber vor
allem ihn nicht zu bekommen
und deshalb muss man dieses konzept
immer additiv zur selbstverantwortung
der spieler sehen in den nächsten wochen
genau so zu leben wie millionen von
deutschen nämlich sich nicht anzustecken
den eindruck hat man heute gehabt bei
der pressekonferenz dass ihnen eines
doch nahe gegangen ist weil sie
beschrieben haben teilweise neid und
missgunst in der betrachtung der
bundesliga bemühungen festgestellt zu
haben als als würde es viele menschen
geben die der bundesliga nicht können
wieder mit dem spielbetrieb zu beginn
wie erklären sie sich das
das kann ich ihnen ehrlich gesagt
die art und weise der der kritik und
auch die motivation hinter dieser kritik
die war ja oftmals er im emotionalen
bereich anzusiedeln
man kann natürlich fachliche fragen
stellen und auch fachlich kritik üben
und man kann auch unser dass das unser
medizinisches konzept das
organisationskonzept kann man fachlich
sicherlich in frage stellt aber es hat
sich doch schon gerade in den
sogenannten sozialen medien war doch
teilweise auch ein hohes maß an
widerstand und ein missgunst bis hin zu
übelsten beleidigungen zu sehen wo man
sich natürlich schon fragen muss was ich
sage den letzten jahren schief gegangen
das war jetzt sicherlich nicht die
allergrößten bundesliga fans die sich da
geäußert haben aber man muss einfach
anerkennen dass offensichtlich für
einige in menschen in unserem land ist
ebenso ist dass die bundesliga aktuell
noch nicht mal darüber nachdenken sollte
durch diese krise zu kommen weil nichts
anderes heißt es ja wenn wir sagen wir
wollen wie das spiel nur darum geht es
ja die klubs müssen früher oder später
wieder spielen sonst können sie einfach
nicht überleben
und vor diesem hintergrund müssen wir
uns auch fragen was ist da schief
gelaufen wie kann man vielleicht künftig
noch besser kommunizieren
wie kann man aber vielleicht auch einige
fehlentwicklungen der letzten jahre
korrigieren das muss man ganz offen
sagen und darüber werden wir uns
sicherlich auch befassen aber erstmal
müssen wir durch diese krise kommen wir
können nicht alles auf einmal machen da
bitte ich um nachsicht aber bei mir hat
das schon einige fragezeichen und
einiges nachdenken ausgelöst
christian seifert vielen dank für die
zeit vielen dank für das interview und
ich ganz persönlich sage im namen von
vielen fußballfan in deutschland
wir hoffen dass wir den ball bald wieder
rollen sehen vielen dank nach frankfurt